hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the ftx crypto cup where
16 of the strongest players in the world
will be competing for the
uh two thousand and twenty thousand
dollars uh worth of prize money plus
also a one hundred thousand dollars
worth in bitcoin
and these uh are the preliminaries so
we're gonna see who's gonna go into the
upper parts of the
uh competition uh this is the game i
decided to show from round one mamadara
versus magnus carlsen
it's a really a wild one i was really
looking forward to
nipple playing against dubo but yeah
unfortunately that game was kind of a
snooze fest so i decided to go with this
one
so without further ado let's check it
out and we're going to discuss a little
bit about
the tournament as we cover the games so
mamidarov with the white pieces opens
with knight to f3 he goes for the
retti uh opening we have d5 g3 and
c6 we have bishop to g2 and now bishop
to g4 black wants to
uh develop the slight square bishop very
early on so he no longer has
any issues in developing the the light
square bishop which uh
can often be a nuisance in uh
openings such as this so d3 uh we have
knight to d7 and
knight b to d2 with e6 now that the
light square bishop has been developed
we can put all of our pawns here on
light squares
uh we have e4 attacking in the center
and
bishop to d6 by magnus and here uh there
are some games where castles was played
also c4 is a known move
uh but here mamidor plays h3 and it is
now
already as of move seven that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what magnus does he
retreats with bishop to h5
with castles and now knight to e7
we have d4 grabbing more space in the
center e5 might be an idea
in the future uh we have castles and now
rook to e1
we have b5 by magnus and now uh a4
attacking this uh
b5 pawn we have b4 advancing
and now c4 so magnus will capture here
our poisson so captures captures
and now rook to b8 getting the rook to
the only open file on the board
and now uh e5 closing up the center we
have bishop to
c7 and now bishop to a3 now
white will probably also grab the
the b file for his rooks uh we have c5
here
uh trying to ruin white's uh wide spawn
structure if you capture here then you
ruined your beautiful pawn chain in the
center of the board
so knights to b3 adding a third attacker
to the c5 pawn
and basically inviting magnus to advance
the pawn all the way to c4
which magnus does we have knight the c
five now and the captures captures and
now bishop to a5 going after the c3 pawn
so mama dark has to defend it we have
rook queen to c1
now the rook will also be able to defend
it with rook to e3 if needed
queen to d7 connecting rooks and now
knight
to h4 we have rook f the e8
and now the knight can finally move but
we want to get the knight over to f5 but
that is something that
white will try to prevent so here first
we have f4
uh rook to b3 by magnus now with a
double attack on the c3 pawn and the
mamidar defends it just rook to e3
we have bishop to g6 now not allowing
any rook to b1
as the bishop now not that arrow uh and
the bishop now nicely covers the b1
square
so momodarov just eliminated we have
captures captures and
now g4 not allowing this knight to come
to f5
we have rook e to b8 by magnus and now
queen to e1
uh so uh mamadirov in a tough spot a
little bit here
uh he doesn't a magnus doesn't really
have a straightforward way to break
through
the the position but it's very very hard
to find good moves for white here
so here we have rook to b2 magnus
grabbing more space here
and now comes queen to h4 uh pretty
adventurous move but
if there if there's nothing better you
might as well try it and here
the knight is under attack so magnus
should do something about this he can
either defend it with something like
rook to b7 or bishop
d8 which is what happened in the game we
have queen back to e1
mommy uh abandons his plan and now
knight to c6 we have king to h1
uh later on you can maybe uh play some
like f5 open up the g
file get the queen maybe into the game
get the other rook over to g1
attack the black king and so on so here
bishop to e7
offering a trade of bishops and here we
have captures captures in the now
queen to g3 as planned uh major officer
basically
only counterplay here is to somehow
execute f5
successfully here so here rook to b1
checked by magnus he trades a pair of
rooks
uh we have captures captures and now
king to h2
and now queen to a3 just nicely
infiltrating with the queen
saying that you don't really have
anything on the king's side and uh
well maduro has to disagree he plays f5
uh he wants to of course open up lines
of attack and now queen to c1 magnus
just
threatening straight out checkmate here
with queen to g1
so h4 creating a square on h3 for the
king now delivering this check doesn't
really do anything the king can
very safely uh go to h3 so
g captures on f5 instead we have g
captures and
now knight to e7 attacking the f5 square
uh but also just uh you know going for
this fork as the queen and
rook are here uh and so here we have f
captures on e5 and now
uh while magnus should capture on e6 he
decides to go for knight to f5
now with this very nice fork and it
seems like you're winning the game
but there is one move that one can make
a white can make here to not lose the
game
so i'm sure you see it even without
pausing the video
uh
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
on spotting it immediately and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course e7 a wonderful uh
wonderful exhibition two here
uh saying that uh if you capture my
queen now with for example
uh knight capture here on g3 i'm just
gonna bring the queen into the game
and then after your king moves i'm gonna
pick up this knight here and then i'm
just up a bishop and you don't really
have anything here you can give one
check
but after i move that's pretty much it
there are no
no more useful moves here for black so
instead after this e7 move we have rook
back to b8 by magnus now guarding the
queening square but this now also means
that uh
the the the rook is no longer guarding
the queen
uh and the there are no threats along
the back ranks so here just
rook to e1 not saying okay you you win
my queen
i'm gonna win your queen so here queen
to d2 by magnus
and now rook to b1 uh
just uh offering that rook for free well
kind of for free because if you capture
it it's
just a nice queen to e8 check and then
uh you're just lost uh because white has
two queens
so instead after rook to b1 magnus uh
goes to rook to e8 and
now queen to g5 now mamidyarov is the
one who offers a queen trade
and magnus declines with knight to e3
and he's
uh in a very tight spot here magnus does
have
some sort of an attack but not really
because this pawn survived and this is
now a monster pawn
so here we have king the h1 and this is
where mamador could have maybe uh
played rook to g1 but it's uh very very
unclear as to what is happening here
okay now you're threatening to move the
bishop and deliver some checkmate but
after something like g6 uh it will not
be
easy for white to find the move probably
king h1
then you can move the bishop maybe try
and break through here so this is one
way to go about it
uh maduro went for king the h1 first but
now magnus plays queen
captures on c3 we have e6 now
a very very very uh fierce attack
uh and the now uh queen captures on d4
the problem is if magnus captures this
just queen h5 and that's it the rook is
under attack if you move it we bring
another queen into the game
uh so you have to capture it and then
now rook to b8 to check
this would be just game over rook would
have to block and rook capture sunny 8
is checkmate
so instead after e6 magnus decided to
play queen captures on d4
but this doesn't help him uh this is
just a much much better position for
uh for uh mahmud yarov we have e
captures on f7 with
check king captures and now now comes
the moment where you have to
really play well and there is basically
only one good move for white here and
that is
h5 but mamijarov did not play this after
this h5 move uh
well if it was played uh then the the
problem is you cannot capture this pawn
and that's a
really big difference as to what
happened in the game now if you capture
it
uh we just deliver check the king moves
and we're gonna deliver checkmate
rugby to check rook has to block and now
the queen guards the rook and this is
checkmate
uh but uh instead bishop to f3 was
played bishop to f3 was a very strong
move ago
now it's really bad uh but you know uh
just because you give up the e7 pawn
there's
there's no reason to give up the e7 pawn
so magnus grabbed this pawn
and now comes bishop to h5 with check
so it's similar but uh the black king
can escape now king to e6 queen g6
check queen to f6 now now magnus of
course will be offering a queen trade
uh because if the queens get traded off
then the two connected pass pawns are
just winning
so here queen g3 but now queen to e5
again offering a queen trade defending
his knight we have queen g6
check monitor of checking if maybe
magnus is up for a repetition
uh but uh king to d7 not worrying about
something like rook to b7 check we can
just play king to d8 and then if
uh whatever white plays doesn't really
matter there are no checks the queen
covers b8 if you trade black happily
accepts this
uh and there's not much uh uh you can do
to continue this
so instead after king to d7 with bishop
to f3
but now comes just queen to e6 and
white's position is very very uh hard to
play
we have queen g3 and now comes queen to
d6
again magnus just shamelessly offers a
queen trade queen to g5 and now king to
c7
taking away any uh weird checks along
the seventh rank
we have rooked at e1 now with a double
attack on the knight but just queen e5
uh yet again we have queen to g6 and
here
magnus just played queen to f4 and it
was in this position that shock there
mama
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh you either lose this bishop here with
check or you save the bishop and then
you lose the pawn with
check and then after the king moves you
will also lose the rook so there is
absolutely nothing you can play here and
for that reason mamidar resigned and
magnus wins uh his uh game against uh
shakhtar
uh in round one of the ftx crypto cup uh
uh
which has just started uh so we're gonna
see what happens next uh
there are so many games in the
preliminaries like i said 16 players
every
round so do use hashtag suggestion for
me to uh spot some games
uh next game is probably nipple versus
carlson if it's not going to be a
terrible snoozefest i imagine it's not
going to be
so probably the next game we we are
covering
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it tough luck uh for
mamadarov he really had magnus on the
run but magnus is very very slippery
something that uh boris posky often said
uh of
uh bobby fisher when they played their
wheelchair championship match that he
was like a little squid or maybe a fish
uh but yeah i would like to thank uh
sami tameen iran urban akram the pilot
uh william rideout and emilio carrado
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event
uh checking up on your uh suggestions
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day